welcome to episode 32 of the michaela
peterson podcast
this is the first episode i'm releasing
after the bunch of episodes i
filmed in serbia so i haven't actually
recorded anything in about three months
so this is new from now today's
episode i spoke with matthew mcconaughey
if you listen to my podcast you might
know
i occasionally get nervous and i was
very nervous for this one obviously
matthew mcconaughey has a new bestseller
out called green
lights and i will attempt to describe
what a green light is before the podcast
it means the period in life when things
go really well when you kind of line up
the universe enough that things seem to
fall into place
whether that's by fate or by a lot of
hard work
he refers to that kind of thing as a
green light the episode was so much fun
can you imagine talking to matthew
mcconaughey it felt like that
i forgot how to set up a camera i was
trying to use
this one and the mic didn't work this
one
that's how nervous i was this episode is
brought to you by
the marty creative co who have been
instrumental
in supporting this podcast if you're
looking for a gift for the holidays i
would
highly recommend you check out their
stuff this
is what their journal looks like you can
get it uh
so i use their journal obviously i've
been using it for about two years i
think i have
illustrations of my original logo
in here uh it's beautiful they have
beautiful leather stuff they have
binders
folios you can go to their website
murtycreative.co that's
m-u-r-d-y creative.co and use codemp
for engraving your goods and to show
them that you came from this podcast
they also have their own podcast
actually
about starting a small business and the
problems that come with that
and the triumphs and it's available on
youtube at
mertycreative.co remember to use mp for
free engravings
thank you murty for the support the
episode was also brought to you
by the auto wild grill which is a grill
i just started using
which i had it earlier it's the best
grill i've ever used it beats the
barbecue
hands down you know when you go to those
high-end
steakhouses and they give you a steak
that has it's called a mired reaction on
the outside
super crispy this is a grill that heats
to 900 degrees
it's about two feet wide
uh 900 degree grill uses propane
it's absolutely beautiful super easy to
clean
and it makes the best steak i can cook
at home
hands down way better than cast iron so
and like i said better than barbecue and
it's hard to beat a barbecue
with code mp you can get 10 off at
autowild.com
that's o t t o w i l d e
dot com for an excellent girl
all these links are in the show notes in
the episode description as well
i really hope you enjoy this episode
thank you for the support if you do
enjoy it hit subscribe leave a review i
really like
looking at them checking them out uh
and sign up if you want for my
newsletter at michaelapeterson.com which
is also linked below uh to stay updated
in case i get canceled somewhere thank
you so much for listening
i had a huge green light the day matthew
said yes to this podcast
i hope you enjoy it
[Music]
matthew mcconaughey welcome to my
podcast
good to be here kayla i'm glad to be
here and thank you for saying my name
correctly mcconaughey yes
some people call mcconaughey there's no
way people actually screw that up
oh they do and then this will go matt
may i know if anyone goes hey matt
mcconaughey i got oh they don't know me
oh oh mcconaughey oh my god well i'm
glad i didn't do that
like hannah hey thank you got it uh i
just finished reading your book
and i i usually read science
kind of based books so i don't usually
do memoirs but
it was a great it was not what i was
like i don't know what i was expecting
but uh it was really funny and i guess i
wasn't expecting as much humor
maybe i should have been um so i wanted
to ask you
some questions from your book uh and
kind of an interview style for the next
hour
absolutely okay uh your book is green
lights
um and what made you decide to write it
given the fact you
you know you you didn't need to for a
reason
well not for a monetary reason anyway so
why did you go ahead and write that book
yeah um so i've been keeping journals
diaries for
36 years i've been threatening
to take those away and see if something
was worthy of sharing for the last 15
never really had the courage to do it
i'm not really very hesitant to look to
look back
and about three years ago i got the
courage to okay i think it's a good idea
um this i i got on with the ghost writer
the writer from the new york times we
met one time after we first met
he writes me and says look my boss has
pulled me from this we can't work with
celebrities and things like this so i'm
off i'm gone
and just as i was opening my mouth to
say okay well i should find another
ghost right
to i looked at my wife and we were like
this is perfect this is exactly what we
need yes
you gotta i gotta go write it so i
packed up that treasure chest full of uh
uh
journals and with a kick in the backside
from my wife who said don't come back to
you got something i
i headed out and maybe it had something
to do with coming coming up on 50 but
not
only subconsciously consciously i didn't
think about oh it's a great time for a
memoir because
and i don't know you know the word
memoir i i open up the book talk about
this it kind of rubs me the wrong way it
has a regressive sort of
sentimental look backwards like okay now
you know i'm sailing off into the sunset
let me offer up the the path i've taken
to you and i and that's why i know i
wanted nothing
sort of it felt like it was looking back
um
but i went away and went through those
journals and
said what themes can i find and i
remember
after about a week i had thousands of
pages they were in big stacks and the
stacks were that of
stories people places prescribes
poems prayers and a whole lot of bumper
stickers
and then i
quickly learned as i was thinking this
stuff was very academic i quickly
learned
ah see what reveals itself don't try to
press anything in
don't try to make it into anything
that's not yet and that's when the the
the theme and the title green lights
came you know and uh that's when i
started to notice oh
you made a lot of decisions in your life
matthew that you took responsibility for
creating some of your green lights in
life
for being kind to your future self for
setting yourself up for more freedom
oh you also got very lucky or
unfortunately they fell in your lap and
you did some things with them
oh you've actually blown through some
yellow lights because and turn them
green because you just denied
that they even existed and sometimes
that i've noticed has been helpful
and then the other kind of larger thing
that that came out of it was i
noticing how all of the so-called
retinol lights in my life the hardships
and the crisis
at some time revealed their green light
assets for me in the future they showed
they had value
the resistance that they gave showed to
have a lesson
that i needed to learn that helped me
become
who i am and trying to become so that's
where that's where they came from
so you've found that if you're having a
bad time in life
ideally something good comes of it
well i think it's trusting that
something will and
not foolishly optimistic of denying that
a crisis is there it's sort of like a
sense of humor
you know a lot of people think oh if you
let you laugh at a conflict
you're you're you're you're taking away
the credit of the conflict and
and and i don't think that's true i
think no sometimes unties the knot of
the conflict and then ties the knot
between the contradictions and
allows people to get through something
um
i've not known always
what that lesson is going to be when i'm
in it i've been through many hardships
that i don't want to wish on anybody
you know um but i did have a hunch
and learned early on that there's a hunt
there's something in this that you're
gonna get don't know what it is
but just stick with it um and then put
the head down and do the work and
something will come out of this and i've
gotten
you know green lights out of green
lights out of my father passing away
um green lights out of that year where i
went insane in australia
i wouldn't wish those on anybody but
they sure revealed their assets to me
later on
yeah one of the things i really
appreciated about the book is
so you talk about that year you had in
australia
uh and you kind of there's a lot of
there's a good sense of humor in there
and you kind of breeze
through how bad it was you go into
detail about you know
you moved there you lived with an
absolutely insane family
and you kind of just went with it and
you know got real you got pretty ill
you had a miserable time and but
i feel like the way you wrote about it
doesn't
neces you just have a great sense of
humor about it right you ended it by
saying you left
laughing um so i was wondering if you
had
advice uh for people on how to take
situations that are really terrible and
end up
taking that situation and not being
resentful when you leave and not being
angry and not being a victim
right um i mean i've always sort of had
a pretty good grasp on a very long view
meaning the pretty quickly even in the
middle of
long enduring crisis i
i kind of know or believe in the back of
my mind and in my heart that okay this
is going to pass
i have hope that this is going to pass
um you know what and if you come out of
it with
you know uh a broken leg
well then you're gonna have a new style
of walking and let's have a cool limp i
don't know just you know
it's part of that tool of when faced
with the inevitable
get relative that you know i'm i'm awful
and you see in the book things that i've
you know i'll break a sweat and go to
work on something to change
my predicament but there's certain
things that as soon as i'm like okay
this is inevitable okay covid well okay
how do we get relative with that
um how can i find the the the the
the assets of this time again not
denying that it's tragic and awkward
for a lot of people in ways that it's
not tragic for me not denying that but
just going okay
well i've got i've got a you know seven
months to a year or even longer that
my kids are always going to remember
where they lived with their grandmother
every single day
there's value in that oh my kids doubled
down on their creative hobbies
because they weren't going to school
oh we sat down for two meals a day
and said our gratitude for prayers we
used to do that maybe once a day now
we're doing it twice
so i'm trying to go those are real those
things are real then
they don't disclaim the the the crisis
and i think
maybe that's maybe that's called having
some hope uh
um you know i have things in there where
people go well you were a victim
you were a victim of abuse matthew you
were you were molested
you were blackmailed in your first
second yes
but there's a difference in me saying
i'm a victim or going yes on paper i'm a
victim and then saying
but i have chosen to feel victimized or
ever did choose
to feel victimized and uh again
there's there's a line my family's my
our family's greatest sort of trait one
of the greatest traits in our families
we were taught resilient
all right you get up you dust yourself
off you look a problem this problem you
work through it
now that's great and it's been one of my
greatest traits but i also learned this
thing
if we are too resilient and we just hop
back up every time we
step in our proverbial pothole and fall
down and every time we just get up and
dust ourselves off
well we become repeat offenders we keep
stepping in that pothole
and we never have any retrospective look
and go
why am i doing that every single time um
so i always joke with my mom and she's
the she's the one who preaches the
golden rule honest doing others do what
i'm doing to you i was like that's a
great one mom but it has a loophole
not everyone wants to do what you want
to do and some things that tickle us
kind of bruise others
so we got a little context and and you
know it wasn't until i was that that
year in australia which was my first
winter
when i was forced to look inward because
i was always brought up for 18 years of
every day is summertime
even if it's thunder and rain you see
the rose in the base instead of the dust
on the table
oh yeah you're bitching about no shoes
let me shave the kid with no feet it was
just
it was just like always thrown like you
just blow by it
that's a form of catching some green
lights because you blow through the reds
even but it also can leave if you do it
too much it can lean into denial and
obviously you know we don't we don't
grow
or evolve yeah yeah and then you can end
up hurting yourself
yeah so do you think the reason that
you're
reading your book you can tell you're
fairly resilient right um
do you think the reason for that is how
you were brought up
or is that something you learned or is
that something more
biological because a lot of people even
with just
overwhelming fame that really that
really
i mean it's hard you talked about it in
your book but
that destroys some people so why do you
think you're resilient
well i know it was ingrained in this
early on and i
and i realized early on that i got what
i wanted
sometimes maybe not because i didn't
have the talent but because i out
hustled the person trying to get what i
wanted
that worked for me i mean i by showing
up again by that result by getting up
off the mat and
knocking on the same door that said no
eight times in a row and when all the
other kids went to the different door
i got it the ninth time maybe because of
my persistence or maybe because the
person who entered the door
was having a better day that day and
they than they were having the previous
eight days
um
you know we we we were raised to
have thick skin sense of humor was a big
thing in our house and you don't
you know you got a problem rub it rub it
you know my mom has beat two types of
cancer on freaking aspirin
and by sheer denying that she hadn't we
found that she actually did
and she was and we finally the third
time shot country were like we're gonna
go to the
we gotta go to the hospital and in her
mind
going to the hospital was a
a a a move of defeat and we're like no
this is
the big c we really need to go for this
one truck let's trust in science for
this one i'm glad we did
and she survived that one too but she'd
beaten two before that by just saying
i'm taking aspirin don't have it
wow yeah you know that resilience is
sort of
ingrained on us and you can yes if you
overdo it
can can can hurt yourself but i've also
found out that we can take more than we
actually give ourselves credit for
sometimes
we're a lot more resilient than we even
allow our bodies can be more resilient
um
you know our minds can be more resilient
it's
we're we've always been a get up and
move on and don't dwell on a negative
you know to to an extent that that you
know we've never wallowed
in the proverbial yellow lights to the
extent that they become
reds we always talk about you know the
false dramas that that that
that that people take the privilege to
create in their life
you know yellow like that they turn red
by dwelling on it or becoming saying i
am the victim and woe be me and you're
like no no no no actually
you could have got through that yellow
light if you wouldn't have given that
moment credit
um and then i was like i say in the book
hey every time
i'm create that false trauma because the
real drama will come
it comes somebody does get severely sick
somebody dies real problems come either
we generate them or the rest of the
world will
so yeah and just that
seems to be part of the part of the ride
in the rodeo um
of what we're doing so that leads me on
to for people who
are experiencing red lights and just it
seems like
fate is against them or like terrible
luck
repeatedly uh and sometimes
sometimes it's fate but sometimes like
how hard do you think you have to push
i'm gonna try and word this properly but
if you're in a reality that you're not
doing well in uh how hard do you have to
push yourself to get out of that
and when when do you know whether or not
you're pushing in the wrong direction i
hope that made some sense yeah no no i
hear you i hear you because
you know yay resilience yay endurance
but it also
is what can lead to the definition of
insanity because you're banging your
head against you
yeah yeah it's not gonna open yeah so
you need to back up and go
maybe i need to approach this look at it
a different way and you
sometimes do that and you look at
something upside down leave come back
and you just dance around the problem
that you've been
banging your head into for years um
and then sometimes it's
you know what going after what you want
maybe not what you need
so actually questioning what is this
thing i'm trying to get to and why am i
trying to get to it
am i trying to get to it because it
won't let me have it
well that's not the best reason to to go
get something
just because you can't have it but can
we find those things that
if when we have those things in front of
us that i go oh no i have an innate
ability for that i actually
love this thing i'm trying to get and
i'm running into real resistance
if it matches if our if our giddyup and
our hustle and our resilience can can be
matched with what we have an innate
ability
to naturally be prone to do well
that i'm for will keep enduring you know
keep going after
whatever is on the other side maybe try
different approaches call a different
play
to use a sports metaphor um but i know
i've looked up
and i see people do it all the time just
banging my head and going
geez you got a bloody nose you're you're
tearing yourself up you can't sleep and
you're sitting there banging your head
missing and on what's on the other side
is
not really what you need and do you want
it for the right reasons
do you think you need it for the right
reasons um
yeah i don't you know that's that's the
art it seems to me
that we're all faced with in every
situation of when do we deem that
situation
inevitable to then get relative on it
that's that's a daily art of choice
making i i think
um and then you've got you know i've got
a brother who's got
[ __ ] luck damn he gets bad luck i mean
something kind of is going to happen to
him
he's responsible for some of it but man
there's some things that my other
brother and i add up we're going like
it happened to him again how did it
happen to him again
he give give it throw that on me or or
my brother or say throw it on me not him
again
yeah what's with what's with that kind
of thing i was that kid
compared to my brother in the family
where it was just like even my
my dad would say guess a number between
one and ten
and he'd always get it and i would never
get it and it started to become a
joke oh it's again you know it's the
89th time in a row
and it was like that for everything
eventually things switched around
but you knew your dad wasn't fibbing
with you sure he wasn't just changing
the numbers so you may like your
brother's getting it every time
there's no way he was that good at
acting
[Laughter]
i don't know why i hit some people badly
he might tell you differently today
um yeah i mean look the other thing is
when comes that time that
we got we have to
to change our way of going about things
because
if we get older and we get set in our
ways my brother's set in his ways
my old my other brother and i can't
rearrange the way
my brother pat looks at life or goes
about you know he can't change that he's
55 years old
happens with people you know um they get
a certain way they're setting their ways
boy
my mom i got story and i tried to change
her for eight years after i got famous
because she wanted my fame more than i
did
i realized my brothers came to me i was
like buddy i just want to amend you
commend you you are doing a better job
and putting you more effort trying to
change mom
than me dad or your other brother ever
did but let me remind you something else
you ain't changing her but we applaud
your effort and it was true
she ain't changing you know she's just
what she is and i've got a brother who
he's not changing it's too late to
to change so i do think there's you know
when is it that's another question when
does it become too late and when is it
well you know and how many times do we
have to have another friend who's in a
rut
and he's in love with the idea
of saying i got a plan of how i'm
getting out of it but to
say he has the idea in his mind
means like ah now i can put my feet up
cause i said it
or i imagined it and 12 years have gone
by
and he hasn't moved he hasn't changed
the situation but he just projected the
idea and then to project the out do you
ever have any other friends that goes
love to see you haven't seen in a while
be in town next week
um i'll look you up and find you you're
like great
and then they never call just because
them telling you i'll be there and
we ought to get together was like enough
yeah
we should hang out soon i have a friend
that does that that just to say it
means oh we hung out or just to say i
want to get out of my rut means like ah
work done so i don't know but there
seems to be an age where i don't know
when when maybe it becomes
too late for us to help ourselves and we
may need you know or can change it all i
don't know you know
maybe a healthy large dose of shrooms
could switch things around
you're right to change the prosecutor to
get the old tentacles reconnected in a
different way
you know that's a great idea you know
for someone who's stuck in a rut i had a
i had
actually a friend of mine in australia
was wild ass
said that exact thing to me he'd been in
and out of all these psychiatric
wards and um his buddy who i was hanging
out with turned him onto shrooms
and he goes changed my life my change my
life's like all the tentacles that they
had no connections like i took them and
they all reconnected and it goes since
then it's been 15 years been great
like are you still doing shrooms every
day goes no just that one time it's all
needed
oh my god completely rearranged and
and things you know started synapses
started kicking up the hair for him
just one shrimp that sounds a lot better
than psychiatric words those aren't fun
yeah i wouldn't think so no okay okay um
i want to go in a bit of a different
direction
uh what kind of advice or what kind of
suggestions do you have
for teenagers trying to
grow up so in the you know 18 17 18 19
year range what kind of experiences do
they have to have or choices do they
have to make in order to
grow up
great question and great challenge for
for all of us adults and parents out
there
you know i mean now more than ever
you know we create something a picture
or something and then we
upload it and we send it out to the
world and we and
wait am i gonna get thumbs up thumbs
down what are the comments gonna be
and if they come in thumbs up
we have a great day so confident it's
awesome they come in thumbs down
we're crushed so the kids today are so
much more uh um
i guess you know what the rest of the
world
assumes or has to say about them or what
they put out
determines so much of who they are and
how they see their own gratification
in life whether how much they respect
themselves how much they care about
themselves how much they trust
themselves
or not and that's different than when i
grew up you know and different than the
generations that grew up before me
so it's a wonderful tool but
how how children and millennials can
find some discernment in that to what
does matter what doesn't matter look i'm
51 years old i've got a family of three
i've gotten on negotiable things that
i've built my life that i love
and are much more important to me than
what someone feels
but at the same time does it feel better
to me at 51 to read a good review on my
book rather than a bad review do i my am
i happy
yes i'm susceptible to that for a movie
i do and even in that you know i've
learned to read something and go
oh this critic was writing a bad review
before he ever saw the movie he just
didn't like me you know what i mean and
i've learned to see that but still it it
oh
or you know oh i'm gonna now go now
even if you're not in a position where i
am aware
of fame and celebrity where people
recognize me children receive
something receive negative comments or
somebody says words to them
they go into the world thinking that the
whole world everyone they interact with
might be thinking that way you know our
mind very quickly goes to somebody
that says something negative that's why
we rub her neck you know and
when highways turn down and slow down to
20 miles an hour our mind immediately
goes to
the lowest common denominator much
quicker than the highest common hammer
or someone and it's not true it's not a
true reflection
and it's it's a false mirror that kids
have now that there are more
false mirrors of how they see themselves
and how they're seen in the world
you can get them you know sometimes we
have the mirrors to the upside
those those skinny mirrors on beverly
hills on in beverly hills at the gucci
store which make us look just slimmer
and true
better oh that's such a good idea you
know what i mean and then sometimes most
of times it's easier to go to that
mirror that makes us look
shorter fatter wider uglier than we
actually actually are well
that's how so many of these are going
out and having engaged in the world
based off of what somebody out there
said mostly strangers
with a lot of them who were like that
critic who was going to write a bad
critique on my movie anyway before he
even saw it because
you've got so many people out there that
they need the little hit of feeling more
confident and the only way they get it
is by putting you down
which is short money you know it doesn't
last it's like it's
it's the it's the guy at the party that
tells the joke come here tell us the
joke
on so-and-so over there eric over there
right and we all laugh
but i told it out of school because i
wouldn't say it in front of eric and we
all laugh
but as soon as you walk away from the
group you disrespect me more
you lost respect it's short money you
know yeah got to laugh was the life of
the moment
but for the long term you walked away
losing respect for me
that that that a lot of that goes on uh
now with
creating how kids feel about themselves
i also want to
remind us all of this and i know when
we're young we think we're going to live
forever et cetera et cetera but
just remember out there every comment
that you put down or everywhere you go
on this thing called the internet and
online and things you say
those are gonna outlive you they're
gonna outlive all of us
and that's writing that's that's gonna
that's already writing the story that's
gonna introduce us at our eulogy and
after we're gone
so think about them because they i think
we feel kids feel we often feel like
they're impermanent
but they're not anymore they're very
permanent
yeah that's a bit scary
what are you doing with your kids and
social media do you have
limits yeah are you controlling that i
can't imagine being in middle school
with instagram that sounds like hell to
me
i mean do you want anyone to yeah do
children need to be that
that conscious again that mirror it's
not necessarily a true a true mirror
before they've actually found
who they are and feel who they are and
walk by in a real mirror and actually go
oh
i look how i feel i feel how i look this
is a true
representation of me what i'm putting
out is reverbing and coming back to me
in symbatico well you get in the ig
world did you you're not getting
that again it can go inflated or it can
go deflated it can go into the asset
section or the debit but it's not
usually true
and to put that on a child where you
know i still
work in all of my work that i do again
at 51
i'm trying to close i've always been
trying to close the gap between
what does i want to do and what are you
actually receiving
there's been a gap at that time in my
life all the time i do it in you know
literally in movies what i want to do
and i'm going
that was that was the take the director
goes no come over and have a look and
i'll look at the bonner and go oh geez
that's not that does not look like what
i intended to do now that it means i
didn't do what i intended to do
or the camera wasn't placed in a way
that it was received
that way so it wasn't a true impression
i'm trying to close those those gaps
child's children today with ig and stuff
there's always a gap
to the upside to in the inflated side or
or the debit side and that's
that's dangerous tough territory to
navigate
when you're just trying to find yourself
i know with our kids
with um i don't want our children to see
something in a movie or tv show that
they don't have some context of
understanding how that would work in
life
i don't want to learn it for the first
time through a fictional representation
in someone's storytelling i want them to
understand
that oh that's how that's how life could
be i don't want them to see
a sex scene until they understand
the the what what sex is for instance
um i don't want to learn that and have
those questions seeing it for the first
time
outside of what me and their mother can
try and teach them
or i want to be the one saying no let's
have a look at this book
this book explains it really well in a
true and healthy and constructive way
oh that's how i want to be the first to
give them it's hard to keep a lid on
it's it's a wild wild west out there
with kids
you know and they get online uh um they
see something the ads pop up
that looks good and tapping on that does
not take them where
they think they wanted to go and all of
a sudden next thing you know they're
down the rabbit hole and i'm like i said
i'm 51 and responsible i have trouble
with it
yeah what do you what what are you what
are you been doing last 40 minutes you
came here for something
deliberate and intentional and 40
minutes later you know where you're so
far from that you actually almost forgot
what you came in here to look for
you know so we're trying to tell them
that the internet is like a neighborhood
they were trying to tell them that when
you go out there's good and there's bad
people that want to do
they want to do good and bad things and
you can't trust everyone that's just
waving
you know and said hey come over here
have some candy you know um and so
we do put limits on it we give them a
time they have you know it's like screen
time
uh amounts they can have and not have
and then also trying
to now the challenge is like well all
right levi if you're making a song on
garageband
true that i'm going to say that that's
more constructive than
going online and checking stuff out if
you're intentionally going to use a tool
that's
still technically screen time but okay
you know so allow that they have they
have messages they have about five
friends
as well as their mother and their
grandmothers that they can communicate
with
we know those parents and we know those
and we know those kids um they don't
you know uh they can't buy anything
you know online with that unless it
comes to me and i have to i have to get
i have to be able to to buy it um but we
try to limit it and we notice how much
you know i don't want them to do it so
much that they forget loving to do a
puzzle
which they also love to do you know what
i mean it's nice yeah yeah
something analog that that they like um
and you know or or or playing a board
game
you know sometimes they get too many
screen time and that's like not enough
it's not enough uh uh it's not enough of
a buzz it doesn't have enough lights and
action and sound and you're like
that can actually be kind of cool you
want to play dominoes
so i'm not trying to be uh you know i
got to check in i'm 51 i won't be no
fuddy dud
about it you know i want to embrace this
these tools they have but we're very
constant about where they go
and we've had a few slip-ups the kids
have had a few slip-ups that we found
out about
we try to let them know hey we kind of
know every if you're going to go
somewhere where you
you know or that question that thing you
typed in
son we're not telling you it's a bad
question
to have but we're telling you need we'd
rather you come to mom and dad
and let's talk to you about that
question you're not gonna get in trouble
for asking that question or wanting to
see those things
but don't go there because there's a lot
of bad artists in there there's a lot of
bad painters and they're gonna show you
things that are that are false so just
come to us and we'll sit down
and find some true versions of what it
is you're looking for and we'll talk
about it you won't get in trouble
you know and then i love it you know i'm
so glad
that that ended before i like i got to a
computer i think when i was in grade
six there was msn and things so i didn't
have it as a kid but i had it in middle
school
i'm so glad my parents didn't have
oversight yet that didn't
that didn't happen but we didn't have
phones writing screens
so it was a bit different it was like a
certain amount of computer time but
you couldn't oversee google searches
thank goodness
um not that i won't be doing that to
like my daughter
but i'm just glad that i missed that
you did you've done a ton of traveling
you had
a couple of incredibly interesting
stories about africa
and going to the amazon um but
how important i guess this is the
question i want to ask how important do
you think
traveling is to be able to understand
i guess how different people are in
different areas or like is that
something necessary
like um in order for people to
understand how the world works i guess
yeah for me it's been incredibly
important i look i graduated high school
i got my degree at university of texas
but hands down
culture and my travel has been my
greatest educator easy
not only did i learn about others i
learned more about myself i learned more
about america when i left america to
australia for that year i learned about
texas my family who i was when it's
another view it's still
you step outside yourself to look back
and you can understand
even where even yourself and where you
come from more i know that's been true
for me
um and then what happens
for me in travel is that the first thing
is you do you do start to notice all
the differences the colors the shapes
the sizes the language the vocabulary
the rituals
and as far as i can tell that
what everybody rich poor socio not
economic whatever color
creator sex whatever one needs to be
some form of happy or have some joy in
life is just to have something to look
forward to a reason to get out of bed in
the morning
because i've seen groups and families
that were i've never met anybody happier
and they had no electricity and they
were in the banjagara in mali
and they had more laughter and trust and
love
amongst them and they were what we would
call poor
and they were working living planting
growing
reaping the harvest day to day um and
have met the
multi-billionaires who were not
happy who were lonely and didn't have
laughter didn't have community and
didn't have trust and
belief in any anybody else
um how the world works how you
you know i mean i'm i write in the book
i think it's i'm for i'm
i don't i'm not for this homogenizing of
us
all to say oh let's just see how we're
all the same i am for
what i am for saying let's say we're the
same is what are our values
that is important to me i think that
comes but let's celebrate the the
the differences it's the shining light
on all the different
the differences which makes it beautiful
it's all these different tribes
that are around it's what i love about
sports you show up in this
the stadium split in half and it's it's
the flags the colors are flown
and the teams are fighting you fight to
the end and then at the end you go
ah win or lose great game and you shake
move on
um uh you know i i i don't
i don't want the world to be borderless
you know um i even
even in america that's part of what i
love about travel in america there's
different strokes different folks they
have different ways of doing things it's
got different colors they eat different
food they look different they just being
one speaks patois another speaks english
another one speaks this way
um different rituals and i love all
those colors and travels what's given
that to me i would always say this one
might if you go to somebody whose
passport's full
you probably can trust that person right
there probably a a good person
because they've seen things they've been
you know they
they've been stripped down to their
necessities they've looked back
into their own world they've learned
things from other cultures
and they see how humanity works and and
it's usually usually you're going to
find
find a good person who's actually
traveled the world
and has a full passport that's one of my
things i hope my kids have
like i'm always like i always say what
do you hope because i hope their
passports get full
that would make me really happy because
i believe there'd be a lot of they're
getting a lot of value from that
yeah i definitely my worldview changed
when i started traveling i didn't do
very much until i was
in my 20s and i was lucky enough to do
some and it was very
eye-opening to see i'd gone over north
america but to
leave north america uh i couldn't
believe how different
certain cultures were russia for exam
for instance
it's like the i how those people think
it's completely different than what i
grew up in so
it's amazing how different people can be
and then you get stuck in this one
mindset of
maybe everyone's kind of like me which
is not
right do you think uh democracy is a big
enough umbrella
to say we can charge forward and
everyone should have that we should put
that out we should do whatever we have
to do to put that up make put that over
every nation
are you saying if i think democracy is
the way for every type of culture
well i mean uh america argues sometimes
it believes that
for in the name of democracy you can go
and and have to take over or what have
you to put that umbrella over because
that's the fairest and truest
means of government that's a that's an
interesting question actually
after going to some more eastern places
i'm not entirely sure if i think that
that's the right way for every culture
i can see why you wouldn't want a
horrible evil dictator
in charge but i do think that there are
some
places that actually don't do too badly
with a dictator type of
political system so i guess it would
matter really who's in power
um a uh democracy doesn't seem to be
leading to a sense of calm in
north america at the moment i'm not
saying saying a dictatorship would be
better
at all but it's not working right now
very well
uh okay okay um
what has been the most difficult part
of everyone being able to recognize you
here
not meeting strangers anymore
um that's what i originally liked about
travel before i was famous
you go places you you you meet somebody
you have a weekend a week
a month with them those hugs
and tears on goodbye are based off the
person they met
when you showed up that week and a week
a month later
i got famous i didn't meet strangers
anymore
people come up and go i'm so sorry about
miss hud and i'm going whoa hang on a
second number one what's your name
number two how'd you know i had a dog
number three how'd you know her name was
miss
number four how did you know she had
cancer you just skipped four big things
you're
you just trespassed it feels like some
people are trespassing and i understand
everyone has a biography
of me now and has a biography of anyone
who gets
famous um so
i had to look for those places in the
world like molly it's like
like peru where they did not know my
name where i went under a different name
where they didn't have electricity to
see any movies i was in
because i needed that at the end of
those 22-day
fuga mundi walkabouts i needed that hug
and to see
that those smiles and tears were based
only off the man they had met
22 days ago when i got there not
that i was not preceded by any fame or
credence for things i had done in the
past or the man i was i was
dowder middle named david in bombard to
call me dowda
and i would tell them i was a writer and
a boxer not anything to do with the
movies
and i was writing about the book they
didn't give a damn about the writer part
they were sure intrigued with the boxer
part
can you please describe what happened in
molly about the boxer part
that was a fantastic part i'm not going
to want get you to give away anything
else but like
one story sure sure so i go over to my
time i'm a writer and a boxer
now i'd come off this film rain of fire
so i wasn't actually i was
in pretty good actual physical shape and
i had a big beard
and uh bald head and you know someone's
like i
had a picture from the set with me with
a bloody nose and it was stunt
blood and i'd show them that i was like
i'm 42 wins and two losses and
this picture here i won this one and
they'd be like wow
well they love to wrestle in africa and
they love to wrestle in mali
so in these walkabouts from village to
village
strong white man named dauda me um
is coming to village he he beat me boxer
box them in so i'd show up and
the young bucks of the of the of the
villages would come up and they'd kind
of
little push and you know kind of and i
was in a few circumstances early that i
was like i
really would rather not get into a match
with these guys
and i remember i would like hop into a
chuck norris
pose or something eastern right and they
would go whoa
chuck norris chuck oh chuck norris so
they would always back up because it
seemed so an
alien to them right um but this one
day we had hiked 15 miles to this uh
village benji matu and i'm doing what i
did most days when i
arrived to the village laying on my back
on the ground
shirtless taking the shoes and socks off
stretching out from a long day and
each one show up in the village that's
when the community and all the villagers
gather around
each village i would go to i was going
to be the knights entertainment i looked
different i was a traveler i was a
new person in their village anyway on
this particular night there's about 25
30
villagers around and these two young men
about 18 to 20 step forward and start
i could do it and i could
tell they were talking at me even though
i didn't know what they said i could
tell they had a challenging tone and i
look over my buddy issa who's my guy and
i said
are they talking [ __ ] he did yes he says
they say they are the champion uh
wrestlers of audi village and they want
to challenge a strong white men named
two wrestling match well my heartbeat
starts going up a little bit and i
continue
stretch and i'm laying there thinking
what i'm gonna do
and all of a sudden the pitch of the the
villagers around me just
hits the roof and i look up and these
two young guys
just bolt well why do they bolt
well because who stepped up in their
place was michelle
five foot nine tree trunk legs burlap
bag with rope wrapped around it
this is the real champion of the village
and he didn't like the two young bucks
were saying they were champions
well without saying a word he comes and
stands over me points to me on the
ground points to his heart
and then points over to the right
my heartbeat starts going up i know this
is a direct challenge for me to
to to wrestle as i'm sitting there going
oh geez don't do this this is crazy
i'm already starting to get up because
the voice in the other you're saying
like you will regret this if you don't
do this you have to
so i stand up in front of him point to
his chest point to my
chest and then turn and head towards
where he pointed
which was to a big dirt pit
here we go villagers are happy now we've
got great entertainment right
i'm going i don't know the rules of this
when you can
bite break arms god hit i don't know but
i'm going with it i'm going with it
so we get in the ring now all the
villages around there's about 80
villagers around
and we stand up in front of each other
i'm trying to figure out the rules and
he looks at me steps forward and
puts a solid hand on my right hip and
looks at me to mirror him i do the same
to his head
then he does the other hand he has me by
the by by the hip with two two hands
i have him by the hip with two hands
then he lowers his forehead
and just rubs it down on my clavicle
here
nooses his forehead down into it so i do
the same now we're ear to ear
we have each other's hips and we're like
two bulls in the middle of this
dirt pit right and the chief comes
around
puts a hand on both their heads and i
hear him go which i take to mean
ding ding and i was correct so here we
go
i'm swiping for his legs they're huge uh
um
i i i get him out of her i get him on
his side he flips me
over one time he comes at me again and i
get him in a headlock he somersaults
over me anyway it goes round and round
for what felt like six minutes was
probably like two minutes
also the chief steps in and separates us
the crowd is going crazy
i'm hyperventilating i'm sweating i've
had these talismans that were sown in my
beard they've been ripped out i got
blood all down my chin
down my chest my knees are bleeding my
ankles are bleeding i'm soaking sweat
and all of a sudden the chief goes do it
this means round two i guess i look at
michelle
who's just standing there barely
breathing hard with a glisten of sweat
on him and he's just straight facing me
going
not happy with how that last round went
which i did pretty good in and i think
this is why i wasn't happy
so here we go hand to hip hand to hip
head down here we go
dot we're off again man here we go again
i mean
flip each other pin each other sands
flying bloods flying spits flying
we go over never never get the other
completely pinned down we do this for
another what felt like
15 minutes but now the chief steps in
breaks us up
grabs both our hands raises them to the
sky and the villagers go crazy
well right after he lets go of our hands
michelle runs off
just like those two men those two young
boys earlier just dart it sprint it off
i don't know where he went and all the
villagers come in and
encapsulate me and start going down
we go through that that night i'm
feeling very good about myself i feel
like i'd
handled you know i think i did all right
in the wrestling match and and i
i get on the roof sleeping on the hut
that night and i'm feeling
very good about my day wow what an
adventure what i'm so glad i took the
challenge i did that
and and i'm laying there and and
the southern cross revealed itself to me
for the very first time in my life
crystal clear in the sky i laid there
for an hour and a half saw 29 shooting
stars
all of these celestial suggestions going
i'm sitting there feeling like oh yes
it's me i'm in the cradle of god i've
crossed the truth i'm the chosen one
this is super
wow preserve this moment matthew
well i'm starting to doze off that doze
off one of my nostrils kind of full of
snot so i kind of
hock up a loogie and i'd lean up and i
go
to spit it off the roof that i was on
into the field
well the luggage never made it to the
field actually the lucky made it about
eight inches from my face and then
boomeranged back across my face like a
wet oyster
i forgot i had a mosquito net tied
around
tied around my head and i remember
starting to cackle laugh
just like that because i was like ah
just when you thought
you had the direct line to
the divine you spit a loogie in your
face
touche well anyway i slept great that
night i got up the next morning
and as we left the village guess who was
waiting at the edge of the village
michelle the man i had wrestled the
night before
without saying a word he reached out
took my hand
it was 15 miles to the next village he
walked with me held my hand for the
entire 15 miles to the next village
without saying a word as soon as i got
to the boundary of that next village
you let go of my hand bowed and turned
around and walked home
that night i'm sitting there with isa
and my guy and i said he said i got to
talk about last night the wrestlemania i
think i did
i think i did pretty well i mean he goes
[Music]
do very very well this man michelle
he's not only champion of this village
he's champion of this village and tree
village back
oh everybody in village think that
michelle going to have strong white men
down
on his back in 10 seconds no you handled
michelle that was the word i remember
very clearly you
handled michelle i wasn't gonna talk
about win or lose was you handled
and then he said something really funny
he goes yes doctor
you come back we make money
intermediate intermediate wrestling
matches right
so i did go back
five and a half years later
showed up on esa's doorsteps and mopti
and told him
i want to do the same trip we did back
in 99. and we got a boat went up found
ali
did the the dot went to village hike to
the village we got to benjamita where i
had the wrestling match
there's michelle michelle had five kids
since then he had a broken hip so there
was no wrestling match
but we had a great night went to bed
next morning i woke up
to walk to the next village 15 miles
away and guess who was waiting at the
boundary of the village
with an open hand which he grabbed mine
and walked me the 15 miles to the next
village without saying a word
when we got to that boundary bowed
turned around and walked back
michelle
that is that is an absurd story
yeah it was beautiful beautiful i get
the tingles telling it beautiful yeah i
got goosebumps
like there were there were a whole bunch
of uh stories you had like one after
another
there were just goosebumps stories it's
crazy
yeah yeah so
after having lived like a life where
there's a
there's a word for it that i can't
remember that i'd like to but i'm not
going to
it's not serendipitous it's something
there just seems like there's too many
coincidences to make
any sense so do you
like do you believe in god are you
spiritual
you do you think you have control over
this kind of
like life that you're living because
reading your book like the last couple
of years for me have been so absurd that
i've been kind of uncomfortable being
like this is just too weird reading your
book made me feel
way better because i thought okay other
people experience this
weirdness so that's great but what do
you think about that all
i do i do um
believing god i you know the spirit the
word spiritual i have
i have a bit of a scathing relationship
with because i think it's become a bit
of an excuse people throw that well no
no i'm not religious i'm just spiritual
and i'm always like to say
let's go back as a prescriptionist let's
go back to the original root word of
what religion means it comes from i say
that
legare and re then legare means to bind
together
and re means again to bind together
again is what religion means
well that's what everyone's talking
everyone i'm talking to that's saying
they're only spiritual is talking about
so i'm like actually you are religious
and let's not give credit don't just say
you're spiritual because
religion has been bastardized by man
along the way
and corporatize and excluded people
along the way let's take it back
let's take the word back and not make it
the
you know the the the the outcast word
um because i don't believe it is so yes
i am religious
um look the i do
i i know we have our hands on the wheel
i know we can self we we can
self-determine
now what is that dance between
responsibility and fate
put their hand in hand i'm not sure
who's leading all the time
but everything from right now back if we
look at it
and deconstruct it it's a science we can
connect all the dots
how we got to right here going forward
is a mystery though
but if it's if it all is if it is all
just faith then freaking let take your
hands off the wheel and run the red
lights
see what happens it doesn't work yeah
short term it won't you you'll go off
the cliff we are steering
you know we're we're steering our by our
choices but then
i've had as you saw in the book i have
had so many celestial suggestions or
things that came in my lap that i'm like
how and where did that wow
um and was i responsible for him
sometimes
sometimes you know
i will i sometimes i wouldn't have met
my now wife
mother of my children who got in a
wreck on the way to the club that she
was where i met her
car totaled and she goes through her
head
what she was taught by her godmother
which is
when things happen like that they're
either try it's either the devil trying
to keep you from going getting to where
you're going
or god protecting you not to go there
and on that night before i knew her said
she said to herself no
no i i'm i'm going there's a reason i'm
going here tonight
i'm not letting this talk car got
totaled on saturday night
usually go home you usually don't go off
to go go have the drink you know what i
mean like okay
i'm calling it a night she said no
she goes what if she one doesn't get in
that wreck and gets there
i don't know earlier so she leaves
earlier and i never met her
i don't know what if she says that's
enough i'm going back home i was told in
my car
i don't meet her i don't know or maybe i
do i don't know do i meet her somewhere
else i don't know
but i mean so there's certain things
that you look back and you add up you go
boy i got fortunate there how did those
how did those dots connect
or i got unfortunate there how do those
dots connect so
i'm not sure i'm just it's again i think
that's another part of the art
of living when we can do it well is when
when do we play who's leading
what where are we self determining and
where is it already written because
everything up to right now was already
written it's done you go oh it makes
perfect sense i look back the dots can
it's a science i can add it up even if i
don't understand it it adds up
but going forward here we are we're off
on another mystery
all right i believe our hands are on the
wheel i don't know if god is laying the
pavement in front of us or is actually
the pavement's being laid exactly when
we make the choice i don't know but
after it's done you're like oh
obviously that was written yeah that was
meant to be obviously that was
the divine order um so i i i don't know
it's a it's a
sure is interesting though to think
about and try and measure at times
forever you know yeah and see and
hard to figure out when you should be
trying to push in a certain direction to
change
and when to let go you know i articulate
the the the the part in the book about
the
the the target draws the arrow
i've gotten a lot of things in my life
out of being very intentional writing
the headline
first and then living the story to that
headline
calling that shot and then writing it
but i've also
like some of the stories we've talked
about
jumped off the cliff and tried to figure
out the hell how to fly on the way down
you know write the story to lead to the
headline because i got no idea what the
headline's going to be
and that's more of a you know more of a
more of a fatalist way maybe
that but it's a dance between those two
it seems
um yeah well
thank you matthew mcconaughey for coming
on my show
i enjoyed it good talking to you and
seeing you as virtually in person
as we have yet yep
good luck to your father thank you thank
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
you